verse leads hey CEO here he is not in
the building but in his building hey gay
number Joe I'm getting on really well
made really what up it's it's a crazy
time right now obviously everyone we're
saying yes lockdown it's really weird
and at first it kind of felt like for me
like a horror movie you know you'd go
out and they'd be like no one around
people are they're wearing their masks
in the shop but now kind of going to I'm
actually really really enjoying it
because I feel like I feel like we have
been really productive during this time
and everyone else has stopped so we like
getting such a competitive advantage
right now because like with with we're
working on the business or finding
property deals lease options deal
selling what everyone else watching
Netflix so kind of feels like it's a big
advantage if you use the time wisely you
know I've started took a leaf out of
your book and started working out an
hour a day which is which is great I've
seen your result was just insane right
man yeah yeah well for quite a long time
you've been finding me for quite a long
time and now you're not very competitive
man we've always been very competitive
and that's why we work so well together
because now we're actually competitive
pulling in the same direction we are on
the same team rather than against each
other apart on my cos were against
nature yeah we're totally against into
that you know I totally agree when when
they said there was another three weeks
I was like great if they'd have said you
got oh everything's back to normal
it's almost like an excuse right now
he's like an excuse to hide away and
systemize the crap out of things hmm
yeah great we're doing so much stuff
that we wanted to do you know how many
you got those things on your onion to do
this I mean you're the the important but
they're not urgent things the things
that you know you should do just get
pushed and pushed away and pushed away
and it's like oh my goodness it's like
someone's come and said to them hey hey
do you want a few extra six weeks
X
no one else has got I'm just gonna give
them you now you carry on working on
stuff and the whole world will stay
still and give you this advantage time
and I'm like yes please yeah I would
love that that's kind of how they often
by the way the weather's gonna be great
and you're gonna be in a nice garden
with you like I'm happy and here's the
thing it's such a sensitive time right
now because no matter what you say
you're gonna offend people in this
season like if I say hey it's a great
time because although what about all the
ill people the people sticking flats but
if I say oh you know now is winning
profits like actually what tends to be
to be productive in this time like so
the bottom line is I don't think about
what I'm speaking about trying to be
correct politically correct and to keep
everybody happy I'm just saying what I
believe and what I think and what's real
for me right now and hope well listening
will see my heart and see that I do care
about people well we I mean we you know
we've really care about that but there's
bad stuff happening to people all the
time all over the world that people does
far worse as far worst of happening all
that like what what about the sex
trafficking problem that we've got
what about they if you look at it it's
very interesting you look at the Deaf
stats and you see like oh 10 million
people are caught the figures they don't
quote me on this it's like 10 million
people have died this year on from
starvation this there's always terrible
stuff there in the world and you can't
you can't just focus your whole time on
the obvious I mean both myself and you
and both involve charities and we give
to charities for that which is which for
me is is my way of opting in the
situation but I think let me do what I
do and let me give what I can but I'm
not gonna spend ages you know how much
money I gave to the NHS I've paid 850
thousand pounds in the last 18 months to
the HMRC to the government Society
I gave 850 thousand pounds to the HMRC
in the last 18 months
so people were pointing the finger at me
saying you know our whole you kept his
money fact well actually in me making
more money
I'm actually not only am I giving all
that money to taxes into the government
having jobs if you you are a person you
have no money you are probably the most
selfish kind of person because actually
me employing lots of people having a
charity given lots of taxes I'm making
the economy better I'm helping the
situation and as a resort mean that's
why I get to live in a big house and
stuff but I don't pay myself a massive
wage my wages ten thousand pound a month
that is a decent wage and the reason of
payments of 10,000 pounds because that's
what I used to serve be happy with I
used to always say I'll be happy and and
and then when I got to ten I could have
very easily when actually 20 actually a
hundred and a lot of friends do that but
I just figured you know what no ten
Gunderman always said I'll be happy on
10 grand a month until if inflation goes
up a lot fine I might have to put it up
a 10-gram is what I'm speaking on from
to my being none of that comes from my
training business that comes from my
property business and I'm good and I'm
happy and a lot of taxes and stuff so I
think right now people are so sensitive
and and and there's so much like I
thought that in Croydon people would all
stand together social media has become
the most negative place right now and
it's its sky more scared of the the
desperate people right now what they
might do then I am the actual freakin
virus I'm more scared of the
consequences of people hundreds and
thousands and millions of people losing
their jobs that I am with the actual
virus oh the the economy I mean for me
the Vice listen obviously you've seen
the death frames the virus it is bad but
the whole way the media and the
government have got about it why well I
don't I don't believe that the
government have got a really really
bothered about all the people are dying
I don't believe they care about that I
think they're much more bothered about
the money in the economy so the way
they're acting is kind of weird and I
kind of bowing to pressure by the media
but I'm like what's the real agenda here
because people are people are dying
way more a cancer and we do things every
day like we're on this call now we're
using Wi-Fi we know we even lower
we know this sort of stuff
scientifically proven gives us counsel
but we don't stop doing that we're not
not locked in little tin houses so the
whole thing I mean obviously you know
you often say in this great quote you
create your own economy you know the
same when we're on the same position
there's no point in one of those
conspiracy theorists let's go do
something about it
there's no point you've gotta just roll
with it and go with the flow it's kind
of what we do but for me personally it
doesn't quite tsunami doesn't quite
think is right if something is fishy but
then I know how much the media lie and I
know the agendas and the government's
and stuff and yeah he doesn't stack up
but I'm not an expert on that I'm not an
expert on on the coronavirus and
everything so I kind of want to just
stay in my lane and just teach people
how to make money improperly and say
look it is what it is this is this is
the reality we're in lockdown and this
is how to make money in lockdown or it
is what it is private property prices
are doing this this is happening the
market and here's how to be this time I
don't want to get too kind of but I
think that's the better way I do that
with anything less with any problem or
anything there's no coin being one of
those bit of people that gets all wound
up on it you know you best off sir do
suppose of it if you check out Robert
Kiyosaki's Twitter right now
holy moley he's he's just like being
buried he's calling it the fake virus I
went that far I mean I don't think it's
a fake bar or something it's realist
killing people it's a real virus but
yeah he's going like but a lot of these
guys are do you see Jordan Belfort's
video I mean jeez I can't disagree with
Jordan Belfort on his video and I
totally I'm like yeah I get what he's
saying
and I get what he said hear what he's
saying get tired now people begin to
even grant cardone grant Conover the
video yesterday it was where he was just
saying look this is gonna damage the
economy so much we'd actually be better
off to just go back to work right now
because this is gonna end up killing a
lot more people and in America they're
more outspoken than I think in America
they're getting at more problems sooner
than what we even Donald Trump though I
can't I
because he I can't see him going along
for long I can't see yeah I can see us
putting up we lock down a lot more than
the Americans put it that way I would
say you know we're we're a lot more
I don't know what's the word we're not
more easygoing we go with the we've not
we've not let anybody go in that
business as of yet no and with how many
members of staff when we got like 30 odd
just over they but and the other thing
though the difficult decision for us was
obviously we've got people as well that
we use for crude things they're
self-employed that we know we know us
through them you can't throw them but no
we've made decision as subcontractors
who were self-employed we've continued
to pay even though they can't work with
like we're really trying hard not some
not general suppliers and stuff not
people that about their own businesses
but but yeah people that are yeah but
some of that that was we have quite a
lot of people that work for us that
aren't included in that number that I
said they were self-employed and
basically what I'm saying is we are
really really trying to keep everybody a
flow and everybody good but jeez its
it's tough from a business I mean
there's there's property in this
business and I mean it's it's a really
weird situation it's a hard line like
Grand Coteau and I don't know if like
1440 people gonna think and he's
receiving so much hype for it I find
these people
but his responses I did that to protect
my business and also we're all firing
people every day the fact that we're not
going to restaurants right now with
firing our waitresses like what we're
all in lockdown like it's very easy to
point the finger of people and and
people are sort of like going on about
brand or going on about and saying this
person is like man this is the top we're
all we're all having to struggle a bit
now when be creatively how we're gonna
get through this this is when you
understand together people that do not
champion entrepreneurs and business
people so not people that I want to know
I wanna I wanna the same time the same
people when someone comes up with a
product or oh this time how selfish it's
like everywhere you know you can't the
business has got to survive as well if
the business card just pay everyone
is not hire anymore but also not make
any money
splice it's not how it kind of works
just just logically because tadhana made
yeah ultimately we're accountable to our
families our staff our customers you
know not every man has dog with an
opinion but it is crazy how people have
got very very negative on social media
and I think it's times and the crisis
like this when you really realize you
really see who your friends are you see
people's true colors and I've had some
really nice people reach out to me about
some very very you know kind successful
famous business people on tubers have
reached out and just like just checking
it hang it's even out the blue hooks but
for me months checking in how you doing
what's happening and that's what I'm
doing I'm bringing in um and we're doing
that as well of our Academy members when
ringing all the Academy members checking
in with them give it a given extra
one-on-one support that we didn't
they're not paid for but we're just
saying no we want to champion
entrepreneurs yeah we've got time now
because that train the trainer's who
we're paying it makes sense it makes
about some of our trainers and sort of
octo-gator Boyd we're continuing to pay
them even though like it's nice as well
a lot a lot of the I find this is a mix
you talk about that but I also feel that
a lot of the entrepreneur type people
like say have club together and I get
you know supporting one another and
trying to help each other ideas I've had
so many zoom calls with people haven't
spoken to me ages who were like giving
me advice on giving them advice what can
you do your business how can we adapt to
this I was talking to Craig yesterday
and he was talking about how he was
close entertainment business entertain
he was talking about some of the stuff
he was doing for the NHS and it's like
you know I do feel like this is you the
people that are in it the people that
that you want to be associated with kind
of are coming together and support one
another the people that you're talking
about the negative people they're gonna
hate whatever man so don't worry too
much
they're just being more to more time hey
they're just ultimately I mean a hater
is just someone erased on themselves
anyway so it's something those people
say to me
I don't I don't deal with behaviors I'd
hoped I just filled my family and my
staff and my customers and give make
sure that they have got good lives
they're paying Wow they've got that
that's my thing I don't have to deal
with all well it's not me you've got
more of anything exposes who you are a
bit more I think so got more money it
doesn't say many changes it rings and
changing money just exposes you in a way
money just gives you opportunity and
power and you can shows you what you
actually just so there's more your true
colors that's kind of saying with all
this time as well a lot of people say oh
I have a I have a time to work out it's
like that's gone now
everyone's got time now so it's now
exposed you know the people that want
time to hate and other people are gonna
hate more because they got more of it
and the people that are working on
themselves and people that are being
positive they don't want to do that
they're making the most of it rather
than hate yeah yeah so true so what are
you doing with your time than right now
love what's happening so my sort of like
my sort of schedule yeah I'm getting a
seven so bit later than usual I'm having
a workout at 8 o'clock from 8:00 or 9:00
doing our work out at two and a half
week since I'm not as fit as you yep I'm
the I'm the catcher bro I'm coming for
ya yeah I'm coming I'm coming and and
then do the mix so I'm doing some work
in the garden
well there's nice on my iPad I'm keeping
you to the team having teammate team
leader mr. photo zoom is what we do
today working on obviously you've got
Samuel 365 we're adding new stuff to
that and I'm liaison a lot with the guys
that are creating that in the IT team
and all that sort of jazz but the cool
thing is I'm also getting time to go for
a walk in the middle of the day with the
kids in them as well so it's been it's
been a weird - I actually kind of feel I
feel in a way more productive that than
I am when I'm at the office they also
feel more laid-back but I'm working for
longer in a way so it's like did you
kind of when you do it at home
I was speaking to Elliott who's one of
our sales guys about yesterday he was
saying it's really weird because he goes
normally when I finish at like 6 o'clock
I kind of just finished he's like now
I'm making calls in the evening but then
I'm going on a big long lunch
it's kind of more more lifestyle and you
realize how many years have people been
saying to me Sammy what can you put the
crash course online Samuel can you do
your training online can you like and
the reason I haven't really is because I
haven't at the time I'm thinking man I'm
already doing soaked but it's so much
time on training people
I'm also spending time on running my
actual property business I'm also a
family about two kids when do I have the
time to just spend a couple weeks put in
this crash course online together I
can't do that and because of that I've
always do I've not even been putting it
off I've just been worming you out
because I know why am I gonna spend two
weeks of my life which is how long it
took two weeks of my life put in a crash
course together which I'm not gonna get
paid to do anyway because people are
going to do it for free or you know
because I found a pound or whatever so
all I'm really doing is always to serve
people and I'm spending so much time
serving people anywhere I'm a trainer
business I don't take a salary from the
training I'm just like ah I don't want
to do that but then I just figured
forget it man I'm in lockdown
did put the did the crash course and
we've had over 2,000 people in the last
when did we put them out week ago two
weeks ago a few weeks ago 2,000 people
in two weeks have now done the crash
course online which is probably similar
if not more than if we were doing live
events yeah it's just and all of those
people that have done the crash course
and now educated and there are a certain
level now where they can now go on and
do deals or joint venture or bring good
stuff in or become a Samuel 3-6-5 member
what they might want then what did they
do the crash bus to see how awesome it
is and they want to be more training
this was actually I'm gonna caddy
remember so actually that is potentially
gonna be very very worthwhile of my time
doing it but I don't never have done it
if I wasn't forced to stay at home
always been on that it's been an [ __ ]
bucket list do
for well over a year but I agree I don't
think without so I'm saying about this
time then there's so much time and it's
an it's literally like is this you like
just bonus time because the world has
Stood Still it's like no luck
I'm in lecture least watching weary kids
burn and what's very press is the watch
and then the whole world stops they used
to go and do stuff yeah it kind of
reminds me like that it's like we've
pressed the watch but oh well the
stopped and we've got all this time to
get to get stuff done that you wouldn't
normally get time to do because no I
don't believe up everyday stuff going on
that's kind of how I feel also really
interesting knowing how to deal with
stuff like I've got a manual and if
basically what I did in my property
business was when I used to do
everything myself
and every time would happen or a tenant
would raise an issue and I'd be like oh
I don't know how to deal with that I
find a way I deal with it and then write
it down and put it in a manual and over
the years when you employ people you
just give them the manual and
occasionally someone goes Samuel I've
got me at a problem it's not in the
manual how do I deal with this situation
all the tenants than this and they've
never done it before and I'm like and
then I have to think and then I have to
go figure out myself and then put it in
the manual now for over a decade now 10
years so my manual is pretty thick it's
pretty good it's pretty you know robust
but now what's happening is problems
have come in and they're not in the
manual and I don't know how to deal with
it I'm like geez I've never had that
happen before like oh one of my tenants
just got Corona and we're living in an
HMO together so what are we doing and
I'm like oh I have no idea so I'm kind
of getting roped into the nitty-gritty
of the business a bit more because
suddenly I don't have no one has the
answers I don't have the answers so I'm
having to really think long and hard
about them and I'll be 100% I'll be
sharing on YouTube and sharing with my
Simon 365 members are we sharing what
I'm doing and what I'm learning and it
time it kind of takes me back to five
years ago when I started my youtube
channel five years ago I've come on
quite a lot since then but now I'm like
young all over again in lockdown in
certain areas like when I was doing the
lockdown financial freedom challenge I
was like I don't know what's going to
I'm not sure and I was figuring out and
I was doing new things you know because
I've never got a lease option agreement
and you sold deals up without viewing
houses from home so it's only yeah yeah
it is
and it's like what can what have you
learned that you can apply so a lot of
you suddenly you like these options
lease options because like yeah that's
gonna work I can do that so I agree I
agree it just does feel weird and it's
obviously you know it does it reminds me
of when you are starting a business and
you are working from home you know that
was kind of a what we did like back in
the day in the day before we got offices
and staff they kind of obviously we saw
us so what stuff it kind of feels like
that you're working from home you
working on iPads we catch it up over the
phone I'm regularly and it's like kind
of feels a bit like that I know you mean
it is a bit of a weird feeling because I
started but most of our staff aren't
able to work because I lot of them are
able to work we're still paying them and
hopefully fingers crossed the government
sort out the whole furlough thing and
that needs to happen they need to they
need to sort that out because I mean
we've got we've got some of us a flight
operations events people about and like
then literally not able to work because
we're not doing events but I think we've
got is it about - that would Peck where
we kept on probably that's still working
it's about 12 and then the rest of them
so we ought to add shrimp to a really
small team as well you know 33 percent
size team and you know it's we actually
in a way we kind of are starting again
in a way because we're not really we're
not be obvious in the properties
actually one of these where we're not at
all interestingly is one of the areas
the government haven't touched which is
construction and rooms full house is
carried on it has load right down bro it
has slowed right down this hill
even though construction workers are
still continuing to carry on they are
scared and now coming up with excuses
and they are saying things like it will
continue if no one gets ill but then
we'll have to walk like it's sketchy and
I must
and a little concerned about the speed I
know we've I linked them project Li so
like it's finished but there's just a
bit of paints and stuff and I'm like
please guys just come finish it you're
allowed but yeah I'm using Corona as
there's a massive excuse I feel and and
it's you can argue with it it's almost
like how can you how can how can you
argue when people said I don't feel safe
even if they're allowed by law it's like
you don't want to be that guy that goes
no you have to because then if they do
get el you then yeah it's a really a
really tough time I'm also having to
think about I mean we had a school
building we just been to Uganda and we
pointed piece of land and we're gonna
start building and now I'm like they're
all saying what's happening
you can do-- and it's just again it's a
minefield to figure out what to do
what's happening and it's another
advantage that has come on a personal
level it's reconnecting with old friends
and family I mean I've been doing a lot
of my old church in the Midlands over
over the virtual stuff which is very
nice because I really miss the church in
the Midlands which which is which is
great I am loving the samuel 365
coaching calls lat oh dude summarise
what happens every week on Samuel 365 so
on summer 365 we jump on a call I mean
like this me and you and we'll talk a
bit about how what what week what we're
doing strategies they should be doing
now sort of stuff that you'd be doing
particular uff challenging a bit of
extra incisors are behind the scenes of
that and they're basically just coach
people so people come on and sort of say
hey I'm struggling with this how can I
help and you'll get as many people as we
can it's so amazing and so positivity
feel we're going to be how many we don't
three three only three weeks but it
already feels like a little community
and people are on there on the comments
yeah you people coming on sharing the
success everyone's supporting one
another yeah
mentioned at the moment you know on
social medias of a lot of the neg heads
us or bruising Heather broke people that
they would never pay they would never
pay a pound to join Samuel fizzies fire
that would save their town they they'll
use their pound for that for the last
packet of beans on toast
like the guys on 365 even though it's
not always a 95 pound a month if you
want to continue being a member of that
and you go like just just for sort of
for coaching cause I know this is a
group it's not one-on-one but for
coaching calls with you 23 and are you
obviously I'm really excited because
I've been good
aren't you about pointing out your
routine and your morning routine daily
routine which obviously you put it on
there as well people do the routine with
me you know do some exercises some
physical exercises some gold set in
meditation gratitude like bang bang bang
every day little often half an hour I
mean that alone I think is worth we just
fun than before so no no no after look I
think I'm at the moment it's why I love
this time is betraying prove it and what
can we add on what documents can we give
people how can we you know and people
come to us yeah man let's do it and we
throw it and so on I'm I'm really
enjoying the samuel 365 stuff and
working on that that's what would be
doing really isn't it Wow assigning a
365 member I just want to say I love you
I appreciate you I'm so stoked to see
you succeeding which many of you are if
you're not signing with 365 member on a
shame blog I'll leave a description I'll
leave a link in the description check it
out one pound for a 14 day trial and
then after night it's 95 kind of month
join the community be a successful
person in these times what did you think
of my financial freedom challenge that I
didn't lock down to challenge I loved I
was great it was really well put
together the video it showed it really
clearly slightly from field some of the
other
one since it felt very raw which I
thought was quite cool as well from this
wall that there you go that's why it's
felt so brought it was you not slick and
stuff that was pretty cool it kind of
you know felt like very real and I also
thought it was really inspirational for
anyone that's that's trying to try and
get some deals done and there's lots of
people a big percentage of the of the
country really want to get property
haven't got time I work here now the
office time but it's like oh yeah I've
got time but it's actually not possible
and you're like oh hold on can we just
for me to show you guys literally start
from scratch like I built my investor
list up from scratch people said well
surely you already have investors I did
it for you I did it to demonstrate that
you can do this from scratch sure I
could have just pulled some strings and
used my investors and stuff but I start
again from scratch in lockdown for my
students to watch and being scared Sammy
oh you made a spelling mistake on the
heads of terms I know man when I see
those comments gee I don't even I don't
even read the comics anymore we have a
delete all the all the losers and if and
I go on it's just clean because when
people say things like it was a spelling
mistake I was like geez you are focusing
on the wrong thing bro now how can how
can you how can you say how can you say
there was a spelling mistake when I just
made 3600 pounds how can you stones are
spelling was they when I just got a
lease option agreement from scratch and
I showed you have to do it and I
literally put the Facebook and did it
and showed you and you can hear the
editor this is why it's like hold on a
second say oh yes I'm not even gonna
yeah anyway dude so excited man so
pleased to be to be to be able to be in
constant communication with you I'm
really glad what you doing guys if
you're watching this video and you
enjoyed it please smash the like button
drop a comment below and let us know
what more content you want to power
probably jump on a call Russell coming
up check in the description Samuel three
to five membership I really hope you
join I want to coach you I want to work
with you I want to see you succeed and
I'll see you next time thanks so much
bro
yes ma'am take care you later